[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hey
there, I/O Live.
I am Todd Kerpelman.
And I am here inside the very
crowded and popular Flutter
Firebase Dome talking
to Michael Thomsen,
Product Manager of Flutter.
Hi, Michael.
MICHAEL THOMSEN:
Hi, how are you?
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm doing well.
Thanks.
So there's a lot going
on here inside the dome
as well as some stuff
going on outside.
Tell me, what are
we looking at here?
What's going on behind us?
MICHAEL THOMSEN: So this
is our showcase wall
that illustrates
the wide selection
of different types of apps
you can build with Flutter.
So Flutter, of course, is
Google's multi-platform SDK
for building mobile apps
for both iOS and Android.
So what we're seeing
here are some apps
that look very traditional
iOS look and feel.
We're seeing an app
from Google, over here,
from our Atlas team, that has a
much more traditional material
look and feel.
And we're seeing
a number of apps
that have a much more
custom look and feel,
where they've tried
to create this more
brand-specific extension and
where the layout of the app
really is an extension
of that brand.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so
what else can an attendee
find if they are exploring
the Flutter Dome?
MICHAEL THOMSEN:
Yeah, so what we're
seeing here is the end
result. And the thing
that's really interesting
is that's just
one of our key components
of our offering.
The other thing is we have a
great developer experience.
So when you try and
create a UI, whether it's
more traditional
or more custom, we
found that there's a lot
of iteration going on.
You may have one notion of what
your screen should look like,
but it's really helpful
to take that and tweak it
and, step-by-step,
to build up your UI.
So for that, we built
something called
hot reloads, which
is the ability
to update the current screen
you're looking at and in just
a few hundred milliseconds,
push a small change
to that running
application, preserving
the whole state without
having to re-navigate back in.
And that's actually an example
of all the great engineering
we do in this project.
So when you use
hot reload, you're
running it against a virtual
machine, which is how
we can do those quick reloads.
Plus, when you're running
these apps in production,
very importantly,
we compile these
to a native ARM machine code.
So you get the combination
of fast iteration speed,
at development time, with fast
execution speed and production
rates.
TODD KERPELMAN: The
thing about hot reload
that I think maybe not
everyone gets at first
is this is actually
running on a real device.
You're editing real code.
MICHAEL THOMSEN:
Yeah, so we do a lot
of really cool engineering
in this project, I think.
So when you run during
development time,
with your Flutter app, you
run on a virtual machine.
So we can push these tiny
updates to the running app
and see that effect right away.
But when you're running
all these apps behind us
in release mode, we
actually compile straight
to native machine code.
So we get the combination of
this fantastic performance,
with sixty frames a
second in production apps,
and amazing stateful
hot reload, where
we can update the UI in just
a few hundred milliseconds.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
I have to say that is great.
As a developer,
I know sometimes,
it takes 30, 45 seconds
to compile a new version.
And those are like the longest
30, 45 seconds in the world.
MICHAEL THOMSEN:
So one of the sort
of expressions we use
for this is you can paint
your app to life in Flutter.
So you can sit down and
collaborate with the designer.
And they can ask you
to tweak the app.
And you're just making
those tweaks on the fly.
And in less than a second,
they could see the effect.
It enables you to experiment.
And I think that's actually
one of the main reasons
why we're seeing all these
creative layouts come out
is that tight developer loop
you are getting with Flutter.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I
know a lot of developers
I've talked to have been
very excited about Flutter.
Everyone I've talked to,
who's really used it,
has walked away super-excited
about the potential.
What's new in Beta 3 that
developers can look forward to?
MICHAEL THOMSEN: There's a
number of new things in Beta 3.
We're announcing a couple
of new partnerships.
I mentioned
2Dimensions here, which
have great tooling for
two-dimensional animations.
We have Infragistics that
announced some tooling
for doing prototyping and doing
co-gen from that into Flutter.
Then we announced a
number of new partners.
We have Alibaba
that's using Flutter.
We have Groupon working with
using Flutter and a few others.
And then lastly, we
announced that we really
think Flutter is now
ready for production.
So I talked about apps here.
Most of these apps
are in production.
So we invite developers
to take a look at Beta 3
and see if it matches
their requirements.
And then go ahead and
use it in production.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well
that sounds great.
And if people want to find
out more about Flutter, where
should they get started?
MICHAEL THOMSEN: They should go
to Flutter.io on our home page.
They can see the
Showcase tab that
has a selection of
these apps for them.
You can click Get Started and
get quick installation tips.
Or you can proceed to any
of a number of code labs,
that we have prepared here
for the Google I/O event,
that you can do at the comfort
of your own home or office.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well thank you for taking the
time to give me the quick booth
tour.
If you want to find
out more about Flutter,
go to Flutter.io.
Try out a code lab or two.
Bet you'll learn something new.
And thank you so much for
joining us on I/O Live.
Thanks again.
MICHAEL THOMSEN:
Thank you very much.
TODD KERPELMAN: Absolutely.
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]